كانوا يرافقون على انفسهم
وفجاه انهار الجسر وقتل معه العشرات
هذه الحادثه الماساويه ليست الاولى من
نوعها في الهند
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
ازمات وكوارث
من اكتوبر عام 2022
اعجوبه هندسيه في القرن التاسع عشر هكذا
تصفيه على موقعها الرسمي عمره
143 عاما وطوله 230 متر
في فتره الحكم البريطاني للبلاد
على الجسر اغلق لمده سته اشهر للترميم
واوعد افتتاحها قبل ايام قليله فقط من
انهياره
كان هناك
يؤدون طقوسا بمهرجان ديني حين انقطعت
الاسلاك التي تدعمه ما ادى الى انهيار
الهيكل بكامله في النهر
السلطات الهنديه مباشره الهندي
وانت تعرف
ني
راسي
كيكي
لم يكن الانهيار الوحيده في الهند ففي عام
2016 انهار جسر في مدينه كونكر ادى الى
مقتل 26 شخصا على الاخر
30 شخصا لقوا حتفهم بانهيار جسر فوق احد
الانهار بولايه ارونتال براديش اما في عام
2006 فقد انها رجل عمره اكثر من 150 عاما
على احد القطارات في ولايه بها وقتل حينها
نحو 34 شخصا
ومع كل هذه الحوادث الماساويه يظل انهيار
جسر موربي واحدا من اكثر انهيارات الجسور
دمويه في الهند وحول العالم